for drew rasmussen i think you really
need to see him still work the power his
average fastball's velocity one of the
tops in the league right now and he's
going with about two-thirds fastball
springer went 1-4-4
in last night's game doubleton scored on
the marcus simeon home run in the ninth
inning when the blue jays almost
made a comeback against the race only to
eventually lose six to four
and a swing and miss springer out on
strikes rasmussen begins the night with
a punch out of george springer up steps
marcus simeon
who homered yesterday 41 home runs
for simeon
and he gets a strike call on the outside
corner there today though against alec
manoa there's really been no antidote
for him so far this year he's the guy
that should be in conversation rookie of
the year two down here in this scoreless
first inning joey wendell's the
shortstop wendell has been performing
much better against right-handed
pitching but he hit a home run off a
left-hander last night just the second
this season that wendell has gotten off
a left-hander 11 on the year overall
with 52 driven in the pitch slider in
the dirt swing and a miss and wendell
goes down on strikes and after the walk
in the single the next three retired by
alec manoa we are through one and there
is no score for the blue jays and the
raids 29 homers and 107 batted in
and hitting 303 today
that's what kevin cash was talking about
prior to the game just shaking his head
and saying
hernandez man he is a tough out
minor into center that ball is going to
be caught
fine catch out there by kirby
and two out two on and back to the top
of the order and granted loud and the
big ready
now down the hill swing ground ball left
side base head zanino an excellent break
around third hands for home guriel with
a throw to the play not in time one
nothing raise
andy andy diaz is coming to the plate
manoa ready
and the one-two pitch swinging a miss he
got him with a fastball
manoa needed the punch out in a big way
and he got it and the rays leave the
bases loaded
steps in george springer standing out on
deck with the top of the card big spot
here in the third for valera and the
blue jays and a ground ball hit to the
right side of second wendell the
shortstop the only play he can make is
to first so an rbi for valera guerrielle
and to score dickerson to second and
it's tied at one and marcus simeon
coming up and the first pitch here is
lined right to second caught by lau goes
back the first double play
they were able to double up springer who
tried to hit the brakes
but he runs himself into the inning
ending double play joey wendell's the
batter
o2 swing gonna miss
got him with a change up
wendell into the club that's strikeout
number three for manoa no buchet will be
the hitter guerrero leads at second base
the pitch on its way and bechet swings
and misses
at strike three in a much needed
strikeout
by drew rasmussen his third of the game
in his first
since striking out the first two banners
of the ball game
so two outs and there's alejandro kirk
he grounded his shortstop
joey wendell his first time and another
one-two on its way breaking ball popped
it up
so we finally got him popped it up in
the short right center carrameyer coming
in and he's there to make the catch and
that will
retire the side took a little while but
a good job by
rasmussen to get out of the lead off
double
kirmyer grounded into a double play in
his first at-bat that was back in the
second
the o2
fastball swung on and missed three
pitches and a strikeout for alec manoa
his fourth of the night that'll bring up
mike zanino and he knows one for one
with a base hit
one two
swinging a miss got him with a fastball
back-to-back strikeout for the noah
lourdes gurio jr who got things started
in the third inning with a base hit to
left field and eventually came around to
score on a ground out
rasmussen's pitch there's a swing at a
high fly ball out to deep left field
margot turns around that ball is gone
lourdes gorilla junior's done it again
he's over in back-to-back games at the
drop and the blue jays have a 2-1 lead
you can't get any hotter in september
than lourdes gorilla junior
a pair of three pitch strikeouts to
wendell
and the first one lined to the right
center field charging hernandez it's
down for the head in to score the tying
around lao meadows trying for third in
the throw out at third base
that's the ruling by ron culpa it would
end the inning the timeline has scored
and a big spot for beau bashette who
grounded out in the second and then with
the guerrero at second and nobody out of
the fourth struck out in that at-bat
but boy he's got a chance to do some
good things for the blue jays
right here oh two the shet swings and he
drives one in the air out to deep center
field this should be plenty deep enough
for simeon here meyer makes the catch
comes up throwing towards third simeon
tags and scores and the blue jays have a
3-2 lead mountain hernandez 3-1 pitch
line drive caught by a leaping wendell
he took a base hit away spinning through
the air and two men retired
now alejandro kirk who grounded a short
and fly to center he's ended two
different innings but he had an eight
pitch at that last time here comes
anderson on top and throwing
popped him up shallow right playable for
brett phillips now he goes back to step
over to his left makes the catch and
after second and third and nobody out
the blue jays get just the one kevin
kiermeier at the plate 2-2 swinging a
miss at the slider down the dirt
retrieved in foul territory by kirk
meyer was running up the first base line
kirk snaps the throw down to first here
myers struck out two away here in this
sixth and the tying run in scoring
position for brett phillips
the one-two pitch swinging a miss manoa
strikes him out and strands the tying
run in scoring position
seven strikeouts
on a grinder of the night for alec manoa
on the hill brandon low against tim meza
first pitch is a fastball line right up
the middle and caught by the leaping
bushet
a line drive by brandon lau smoked right
up the middle
beau was right in the middle of the
diamond and he left his feet at the
exact right moment and he stares out
number one
taskers oscar's over three waka deals
and the first pitch ground ball base hit
into left field coming around third
springer wants to score mar goes up with
the throw that gets cut off and the blue
jays have a 4-2 lead and now here's
alejandro kirk he's over three in the
game wacho ready in the pitch
strike three call over the outside
corner
that'll take care of kirk and that'll
take care of the blue jays
here in the eighth but they add on
and the rays are gonna stick with mike
cenino and the pitch swinging a ground
ball towards buchet he's got it short
way to second to get the fielder's
choice and retire this side a couple of
walks made it interesting
joey wendell
with a winning run on here in the ninth
the 0-1
fastball hit high in the air out to
right field hernandez runs underneath it
screaming for it he's got it to finish
the ball game
it was a white knuckle ride to the
finish but finally after the bases were
walked loaded with two outs in the ninth
inning romano and the blue jays can
exhale
they have evened up this series with a
4-2 win over the rays
you